Just when it seemed the champagne days were a thing of the past...
...for Asia's investment bankers,...
...along comes the biggest IPO anywhere in the world this year:...
...the state-owned Postal Savings Bank of China...
...officially announcing its massive 8.2-billion-dollar IPO on Tuesday,...
...eclipsing the other major new listings of 2016.
This is China's 6th biggest bank,...
...with more than 40,000 branches spread across the country.
It's also going to be a 130-million-dollar payday for the banks putting the deal together.
That includes big US players like Bank of America, Merrill Lynch,...
...JP Morgan, Morgan Stanley and Goldman Sachs.
This high-profile IPO flies in the face of a rough year for China's economy.
Banks are having a tough time and stock markets are volatile,...
...with Shanghai's index down almost 15 percent this year.
Investors are also deeply worried about a growing pile of souring loans...
...at major banks across the country.
But that's where the appeal of PSBC comes in.
Its stack of loans is much lower than the national average...
...and its jaw-dropping total assets add up to more than a trillion dollars.